i really wish in that moment you would
have like right when you under the stage
peel off the gloves you would have just
looked and been like a bit dramatic but
okay
oh say can you
see i [ __ ] do you sometimes seeing let
it go in the shower best reverb of all
time i
finally found him i finally found her
[Music]
it is so great
[Music]
we have a video of you working on
firefly lane um from home so let's see
the video
okay you ready
action
oh yes yes
i mean take that when harry met sally
like
so the kids are used to shouting coming
from the other room now
so you're in the clear you gotta wonder
what they were thinking yeah you could
just now always say you were working oh
we were working on a project
yeah no my adelaide said to me the other
day that she and neily give each other a
look when
they hear something weird and i said
what do you mean by weird like what do
you hear that's weird and she was like
well you know if we hear like shouting
or you and dad laughing really hard
or you know there's something always
about you grabbing dad's butt
and i was like okay okay maybe we should
be
more quiet about these things or show
them how fun relationships sound
[Music]
what did you have to learn to love about
yourself when you were when you were a
kid
like other than like your eyebrows are
weird like aesthetic things but
anything like personality-wise i feel
like a lot of creative people were
always kind of introverted at first
i think we all have our insecurities and
for me
body image was it was a really big thing
and i've been very vocal and open about
my experiences with eating disorders and
just
how now my fiance you know is so
supportive and it's like finding new
ways to feel
centered and not reverting back to old
ways and it's
i think it's so admirable for for both
of you to be such strong advocates of
talking about things that a lot of
people think are
taboo or shameful it's like we all just
need to say that
we all go through these things and we're
not crazy and no one of us
is alone you know and i yeah i just
think that we all have those little
things
yeah and i also think that we're always
i literally just
was talking about this yesterday with
someone i was like well i'm always like
working on being the better version of
myself for the best you know
there's always got to be a better i
don't know i like progressing or
whatever so i don't think that they're
good for everybody like it's one of the
good things now about social media
there's so many
so many bad things i think that make us
feel isolated about like technology and
social media but actually
to that point like breaking the taboo
the more people reach out and say hey
i'm feeling this way
and then you feel that swell of love
whether you're in the public eye or not
to say like i've been there you know i
know what you feel like
um there's actually been a really
amazing community of people to say like
i got you and
that's been a cool thing to see yeah
that's amazing josh because that's
actually the community that i found on
on my social media platforms
which inspired me to write my book
because all these people were reaching
out talking about their insecurities and
prefacing it by saying
oh but you're an actress you probably
have no idea what i'm talking about i'm
thinking
i'm an actress and i know 100 what
you're talking about and let me tell you
why
and it just inspired me to then share my
story because none of us are above
sharing our stories
absolutely yeah
[Music]
um so in your book you talk about what
happened uh to you at the super bowl can
you tell that story because
i mean i i have had to do that at the
super bowl as well and it is already
nerve wracking
can you tell everybody what happened
yeah i was what what year was it it was
1990 i think it was six i think it was
1990
no 1995. super bowl 29
and i was asked to uh sing the national
anthem which is a
you know huge honor and and yet at the
same time it's it's it's terrifying
there are i mean that goes worldwide and
you don't even want to
barry manilow had said to me right
before i did it he did it the uniform
barry's been a great friend through all
these years and he said kathy
no matter what you do do not look up at
the scoreboard and look at how many
people are going to be watching
don't do it oh good don't tell her that
yeah well i'll tell you the story it was
you know we have something called final
looks in our business which is
we're ready to go uh hair makeup get
over there do whatever final touches
you're gonna do because it's
we're ready and um so um
my hairdresser by mistake does hairspray
on me and
goes in my right eye boom right in my
right eye and i'm going blinded from
that
and then my my makeup artist is working
on me on the other side and she
has a a um a wand a mascara one
boom right into my left eye
i'm walking like they had to lead me
by you know it doesn't you don't they
don't wait for you at the super bowl
they're leading me out and i can hear
that everybody scream and i can hear all
this noise
and i'm going oh jesus help me jesus
help me
i get there and then of course the
orchestration starts the ban
you can hear the orchestra full
orchestra and and it's time for me to
sing
of all the lyrics oh say
can you see
oh my god that's awesome
[Music]
glennon you you write about the public
fallout from your divorce i'm
obviously going through one right now um
it's horrible there are so many hard
parts
um my the hardest for me is the kids
that's the hardest for me
um you know i always i think as women
especially we're trained alicia i were
talking earlier
to take it all on and you can deal with
it and you're fine but it's your babies
that you worry about so what
what was the hardest part because you
also did it publicly
um you know that's a hard thing as well
what was the hardest part getting
through all of that
yeah so i think no matter how public
things are the hardest part of divorce
is
is always the kids right um we're
trained to believe that what we have to
avoid at all costs is a broken family
and that a broken family is a divorce
what i came to believe is this um i
stayed in a broken marriage for a long
time for my children and one day i was
looking at my daughter and i thought oh
my god i am staying in this marriage for
her but would i
want this marriage for her and if i
would not want this marriage for her
then why am i modeling bad love and
calling that good mother
right yes and the reason is because
we've all been trained to believe
that a good mother is a martyr right
that what a mother does
is just slowly dies right hides her
ambition and buries her feelings and
buries her sexuality and her dreams in
in honor of her children and we know
that that's the worst legacy we can pass
on to our kids which is why carl young
said there is no
greater burden on a child than the
unlived life of a parent
yeah not a divorce the unlived life of a
parent so
you know i didn't leave a bad marriage
in spite of being a mother i left
because i'm a good mother
right and because a good mother is a
model is a model not a martyr
well and i it's so interesting that you
brought that line
that's the book that's my favorite in
your book that's my favorite line from
it because
and and not to put this on you it was
just one of those things that was that
thing i needed to see
to make a step in my life and not just
for me but also for
my current husband i'm like this isn't
happiness you know for both of us you
know like i feel
both of us deserve better and neither
one of us would want this for our
children and it was like
reading that line like so hit home for
me and not selfishly but for the family
it's like well i don't want this for
anyone in in this
scenario right now and it was just such
a powerful
piece of knowledge that seems so logical
but it's never been worded like that to
me
so i mean thank you so much um it it
you really i said this in the break
before you came on but you i know you
get this because you get so many people
just raving about you and
probably in tears saying thank you so
much and you've changed their lives and
and and everything but it is such a
superpower that you have to be able to
help lead others to theirs and and and
it's just it's a beautiful thing you do
[Music]
sarah live there's so many new york
moments um that it's been
crazy for me to even think about but
probably my my one of my biggest
and most fond memories was the snl
40th anniversary party yeah after the
after parties are always
fun but this after party was the 40th
anniversary and everyone
who was anyone it was just crazy amount
of people were there
and as soon as i walked in paul
mccartney was calling my name to go on
stage
and he was there with dan aykroyd and
jim belushi and i got on stage and dan
aykroyd said
kid i've done this for 40 years it's
your turn uh
uh you got to rock this party and so
there was no band
it was just me and paul mccartney and
and dan we did one and we just had
people come up from the
crowd and play and jam out and play
songs and the end of the night
we're on stage seeing bill murray and
chris rock and
chappelle and dave chappelle goes me
jimmy if you
ask nicely i think he's here but if you
ask you could probably get prince to
come up
what and so at the end of the night i
just go and it's just like probably
two three in the morning i go prince if
you're there
i'd love to have you come up and sing a
song you bubba and all of a sudden the
crowd
parted and this purple smoke i swear
it's like
true it's almost like his legs were not
touching the ground
his legs were just kind of floating and
he was floating
across the room and i go oh my goodness
he comes up and he peels off these
gloves and he hands me his gloves and i
hand him a guitar
and not only does he play he plays let's
go crazy oh my gosh
i really wish in that moment you would
have like right when he entered the
stage
peel off the gloves you would have just
looked and been like a bit dramatic but
okay
cause that would have been everything i
guess we're gonna do this i
rocked the house it crushed it was epic
that's so cool too and the the i don't
know the i've never
i'm saying a bunch on this no but i've
never like um like hosted it and
and i don't know if i will now because i
bla i was in new york when blake shelton
hosted
and it's so much time that y'all all
spend together i mean y'all are like
family like non-stop so i can imagine
that that kind of party where
you know you've got everybody there and
you're celebrating all these friendships
that are like
deep friendships you all are around each
other you live
you live with each other basically at
saturday alive i mean we were kind of
it's like a dorm room it's like
horatio sans and i were office mates and
we
you know we we had blankets there we'd
stay up all night trying to write and
i remember dan aykroyd coming in just to
say hi you're the new guys i just want
to say hello to you guys and we're like
freaking out was dan akroy like oh my
gosh she's like do you want me to show
you where
me and john used to go i go okay and he
goes
you know we had all the keys to all
these rooms in snl
he brought me into ratio into someone's
office snuck through their window and
we're out on the 11th floor
and there's like grass up there and like
koi pon it's the weirdest spot what and
him and john used to go up there and uh
write yeah they're doing it yeah
what do they call that what if we call
that on tour a safety meeting
that's everybody always said oh they're
at a safety meeting it's like okay
um so josh also did musical theater as a
kid we both actually did
not many people know this but josh was a
guest on the pilot episode of the show
because he's super cool and nice and
totally came and did me a solid
but we talked about our musical theater
backgrounds and we realized something
strange as we talked take a look
i remember thinking though when i first
was introduced to musical theater oh
we're just all cool with like
they're just she's just gonna break out
in song like as if it's normal like
she's just like talking and that's the
thing i'm feeling a song so i'm just
gonna do that
i kind of thought that was awkward it is
awkward and people who are sometimes a
little weird about
is it me or is it just the way he smiles
that leaves me breathless
how can i not tell her that i love her
so like adina menzel
that is crazy crazy right crazy she is
you got to tour with a dina menzel
we're right i mean she got the tour of
joshua no no no no we are we are about
to
grow together she is um truly oh you're
about to
we're about to hit the road i thought
you just no no we're about to do it no
she's just unbelievable you know what
you know how it is
and all at once
my life starts to have meaning
all that was i can't ever
look back
but crazy that y'all are going to be
there at the same time right because
like same time
you're going to get to sing let it go
well i don't know i mean she
i mean she sings let it go and i just
listen i'll just go back and listen i
would like to hear you seeing like
i would like to hear myself sing let it
go but you know what sometimes you just
got to let those dreams go you sometimes
sing let it go in the shower
best reverb of all time i finally
[Music]
[Applause]
i love you so much for doing that i just
remembered after watching that
he literally learned that right before
we did it like we
i we we put that together right before
we did it and you were so gay well you
only gave me one line i mean it was
really it was
whatever and look you've you've uh
you've you've graduated from stools to
look at this beautiful couch
and look and i have a band now like a
full band it's all amazing okay we could
do it look what you helped me
oh no listen and it is now
you